you know cause everyone well uh what
year did you start like when was your
first video the weight loss video won't
remember what year that was
which way it allows me to wonderful
times and I failed you know what pissed
me off though it's why I would do this
weight loss [ __ ] right right
and then I would go on these shows and I
would lose like ten pounds right and
then maybe I'll gain back 20 if somebody
meets me and they go bro can I tell you
something I actually lost a hundred
pounds and you've inspired me you know
so I
I only recently lost the weight just
like maybe a year and a half ago me bro
you're looking good right now so I'm
trying to you know just eating like a
normal human being man I would eat like
I would literally eat like I'm going to
the electric chair tomorrow bra everyday
talk to him and that's exactly what I
mean like last meal like last meal yeah
I like the quantity you know what
happens like cuz I grew up so [ __ ]
broke right I don't know what an
appetizer was right you know usually it
would said cash starts to flow in it's
like oh I could try this try that you
like Korean parents are like make sure
you finish everything so I that she's
beaten inside me yeah so it's like left
what the [ __ ] are left over I'm the
exact same way I like if you go to a
Korean restaurant with me all the punch
ends we call him Justin PPO he puts all
the ppl means mix and then just mixing
them all but one last bite
I felt the meal was incomplete unless I
had for those silver rice bowls bro you
know Roy Choi chef Roy Choi he calls me
MC for bops because when I went to his
Korean restaurant pot at the Lion Hotel
like I I eat everything he brought out
like click cleaned it you know I mean
Africa style cleaned it a for bops and
yeah I could eat more like that's that
was a thing but rice is my vice so I
can't say stay away from my [ __ ] right
so like if I had there's no way I could
eat one bowl of [ __ ] rice that's like
tell me to eat one taco it's one Pringle
you can't do that yeah because our
[ __ ] punch on tell it Josh so they
set me up for [ __ ] failure right you
know it's weird too because Korean
parents had this weird habit of calling
you a fat [ __ ] butt and ask you why
you're not eating
yeah [ __ ] is that yeah yeah yeah my mom
would literally she would do that she'll
do this Thanks give me two when I go
back to Sacramento great you know I'll
sit there and then she'll be happy that
I lost this weight cuz I'm healthier
right yeah and then I'll sit there and
be like I'm done with this food that
she'll be like what's wrong with my food
literally called me a fat [ __ ] for 30
years what are you saying right now and
there should be mad then I'll eat it
that she goes my dad would do the same
thing he'd be like you know the dangers
of ramen and how much you shouldn't and
wisecracking around me my parents used
to do this [ __ ] that I stand a bit about
it but the Korean parents are one of the
only parents that will sock you in the
mouth and ask you why you're crying
my dad has socked me in the face and be
like yeah well you cry yeah like my dad
was to hit me and be like you know why
right now the mental yo they used to do
you have parents I used to hit
themselves like you're doing this to me
the next level that's been so crazy my
dad used to do this other [ __ ] where he
would take his fist I'll go and then I
would have to punch my disrespect that's
some like mental yeah and then he did
that to me too but you'd have trained
where you come in hard and it's all good
my dad is so funny dude like people
don't realize like how bad like Korean
pears would be to share their sons oh
they didn't give a [ __ ] I once got beat
so bad I couldn't go to school for a
week and I thought that was just normal
like my dad beat my ass so hard both my
ass cheeks turned purple damn and I
could have sit in a chair right and so I
was like and when I got older I was like
was the worst thing you got hit with you
remember oh man I got hit by everything
ah let's see this let's go down the
category you know what the thing I hated
the most actually I'm not sure if you
guys got hit by this [ __ ] uh-huh but you
know those little green bamboo sticks
that used to hold up plants
oh yeah I called that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
silent but deadly bro you know I just
want to say it was you could hear it cuz
the wisp but it was so fast you couldn't
see it I see
so it was like you're gonna get your ass
beat by a ghost right I call it the
delayed too because they would whip and
hit my back and I'm like you don't feel
it that bamboo stick comes under the
same family as a radio antenna yes dry
cleaners kids my mom would have the
hardest time like ripping off that I
love you customer yeah I love customers
yeah both your parents do a dry cleaning
well my own clothing stores as well for
sure but I clean his [ __ ] my dad was a
when I was younger my dad was a table he
was a master like a tech window man oh
[ __ ]
so he wouldn't he wouldn't physically as
my healing like there's a couple times
where he might have done it like a
spinning back-kick mound there's more of
like like like a do push-ups for like 30
minutes and have your feet up right
paying or like oh my god did you have to
do the [ __ ] see more endurance oh yeah
yeah oh yeah the remote control the two
remote controls man oh yeah green people
punish their children the most creative
[ __ ] man yeah like I remember this
one time like I I got caught cheating in
school and so my teacher called my
parents and I remember I went because a
white lady like you you don't grow up in
a Korean household that's like I beg you
don't tell my parents please don't tell
my parents is a life and that's
interesting was like I didn't realize
that she wasn't white her last name is
Escobar she's Mexican but she doesn't
speak Spanish right and so she don't
give a [ __ ] just another version of
Korean people 100% I was like okay and
so I was like I beg you please don't
tell me she goes David I have to do it
and then when I got home she had I had
to do this [ __ ] right to get on my knees
I had to hold this I remember it was his
green plastic chair like this and then
if it dropped down it was so heavy it
was smashed my head because it smashed
my head and I dropped my head and my dad
would hit me in the ass
I have huge lump on my head and a huge
bucket on my ass
that's nice were ruthless dude now let
me ask you now because my parents too
you know shoutout to my parents they
were very yeah they were very very
physical back then but are they now soft
he's now or what no my mom my mom
[ __ ] [ __ ] horny dude she's of a
[ __ ] no she's so funny though but me my
mom were like best friends we get along
very well but she's always been an
extreme lady my father's a pastor dude
so really he's a pastor we own the own
own a beauty supply store too so so my
mom has gotten